good stuff by nikita vichygov  that's actually a move you can play um  you can find easily i mean this is the  last  piece not uh  and not working magnus game is over  assuming  it will have ended peacefully yeah it is  it is a door  uh nothing much has happened magnus  discussing is a great game after  radek is saying i will crush you next  game with the black pieces  magnus saying i don't know i'm wearing  champion i'm white shouldn't be so sure  and then now magnus apologizes for all  this question  and off they go so again  yes one one rapid game if it's a door it  will be two more so  very tense match  um i like this position here let's stick  here it's such a rare position it's a  full piece down